hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the eighth and
final article of question two of Prima
second day of the summit a low-key I
Thomas Aquinas is considering the
question whether any created good could
constitute human happiness is there
anything other than God who's the
uncreated good that could really make us
completely happy now he's not he's not
asking the question whether things can
make us happy or not because clearly you
know looking at the other discussions in
this this section we can have limited
happiness according to him in all sorts
of other things that are way smaller
than the scope of what we're going to
consider here you know in pleasure for
example or goods of the body or even
wealth but those aren't the ultimate
happiness our final end as he says so
he's considering things now that are of
a you know you might say a significant
metaphysical scope and he's going to
consider three objections they're always
called three arguments against the
position that he's going to hold and two
of them have to do with objects that you
know you
say those are pretty good things those
are substitute maybe we don't have to
get to God in order to be happy just
enjoying these and then the third has to
do with our own capacities to enjoy
happiness and to desire things so the
first one he says that it would seem
that some created good constitutes human
happiness why and here again he quotes
pseudo Dionysus on the divine names
he says divine wisdom unites the ends of
first things to the beginnings of second
things and Thomas concludes from that we
may gather that the summit of a lower
nature touches the base of a higher
nature now in order to understand this
we didn't need to know a little bit
about
pseudo Dionysus his background pseudo
Genesis was at neoplatonist and the
neoplatonist believed and they weren't
the only people who would believe this
that there were degrees of being so for
example you know there's bear being like
that of rocks or stools and then there
is living being which includes plants
animals human beings perhaps all their
higher entities as well and then there's
animate being animals right and that's
that's a higher stage right and then
there's rational being which includes
human beings and then there'd be higher
things above that within the Neoplatonic
way of understanding it and it for a
christian neo plainness these are going
to be angels for a pagan it would have
been the dye Monet's but it's the same
sort of scheme and what he's saying
there is when you're at the highest part
of a lower nature it sort of impinges
upon the next highest thing in the scale
so that in mind he says since an angel
is above human being in the order of
nature it seems that a human beings
happiness consists in somehow reaching
or attaining to the position of an angel
we can summarize this as moving from a
lower human nature to a higher angelic
nature would make
happy now there's a lot that could be
unpacked from that why would being an
angel be making us happy you got to put
aside all the sort of cartoonish and
sitcom ideas that you have about heaven
or angels you know they don't just sit
around play harps and have a little halo
and wear white robes no they would be
active within the cosmos and doing
important things and understanding the
nature of the universe better than us
though those are all sort of background
assumptions that Thomas is making that
in our own contemporary culture I think
many of us don't have so there's a
certain kind of plausibility to this
imagine that you were raised to a higher
state than what you currently are the
next one he talks about another
metaphysical principle that again we
probably don't relate to that well in in
our own time and culture so he talks
about the macrocosm and the microcosm
the microcosm means the totality of all
that exists in the universe living not
living conceived of as a cosmos right
the greater the larger cosmos and then
the idea was that the human being is a
micro cosmos so everything that's out
there in the universe were in some way
related to this is again an ancient idea
not one that is widely accepted today
but imagine that that was actually the
case that somehow we as human beings
perhaps because of our intelligence are
really at the center of and in some way
represent the cosmos but in an imperfect
way what if we were to be united with
the cosmos in a more perfect way he says
the last end of each thing is that it
which in relation to it is perfect
so if microcosm is imperfect maker
Kosmas perfect that would be than our
last end so he says the part is for the
whole as for its end so our happiness
would consist in the whole universe as
he says of creatures
by that created being everything that
God has created so it would be
everything except for God himself itself
whatever God happens to be so that's
another possibility the third argument
that he makes is an interesting one this
is this is a one where a lot of people
get into theological disputes and it's
occupied quite a lot of ink over the
last century this question about whether
our desire could really be for an
infinite thing like God he says human
being is made happy by that which lulls
their natural desire this is a natural
desire right
lowing it literally the word there is
totally theater quiet hot Appetit them
right what what the appetite or natural
desire totally rests in is is entirely
satisfied by you could say so we remain
happy by whatever it is that does that
body says human beings natural desire
does not reach out to a good surpassing
our capacity now we're a limited being
we're a created being
we're a imperfect being so what that
would imply is that unless we have some
sort of capacity within us that we don't
know about we can really only be happy
with created things that we can in some
way relate to and our will can therefore
desire so he says since a human capacity
does not include that good which
surpasses the limits of all creation
that would be something beyond nature it
seems that a human being can be made
happy by some created good some some
created good whatever that happens to be
what would constitute human happiness
Thomas says this actually doesn't work
and here he's going to make an argument
that depends a little bit on his
anthropology so it's important to
understand that earlier in the summit a
loggia when he has discussed the nature
of the will he's asserted and argue
for the the point that what the will
really desires and the will is rational
desire it's not simply making choices
it's it's a kind of desire is the
universal good
so it's desiring something and that's
not this bit of water but something more
broadly speaking like satisfying thirst
in general or you know maintaining the
body and whatever that happens to be or
the good of the body and the salton we
can go on and on those are more general
so he says it's impossible for any
created good to constitute human
happiness why happiness is the perfect
good which the appetite entirely rests
in right totally terror
quia tots otherwise it would not be the
last end if you have anything more the
you know if you if you have happiness
and you're still like yeah happiness is
good but I'd really like that thing over
there you don't have happiness that not
not in the fullest sense not according
to to Thomas Aquinas so happiness is
self-sufficient and so what would that
look like that he says the object of the
will of human appetite is the universal
good just as the object of the intellect
as the universal true so nothing can
actually satisfy or you know provide
rest to or make us you know completely
quiesce you know who essence you could
say if we want to be sticking to the to
the language very closely none of that
can do that for us except for the
universal good because in any other case
we'd be like well I also like that thing
as well so he says this is not to be
found in any creature but in God alone
because every creature has goodness
whatever goodness it has by
participation whatever goodness a
creature has and it could be very great
goodness is not complete goodness
according to Thomas so it says this is
why only God can satisfy the will of a
human being
so God alone constitutes human happy
is not created goods not to say that
created goods aren't important or don't
play a major role in human happiness but
by themselves they don't suffice and
here it's good to look at the responses
that he has to these objections Thomas
says listen you know moving from a lower
to higher nature that would be good but
even the Angels look to God so if we got
to angelic status we would still be
ordered to something higher yet so it's
not the moving to an angelic status that
would actually make us completely happy
right the second one he says if a whole
being at the last end but ordained to a
further end then the last end of a part
thereof is not the whole itself but
something else so how does this play in
with microcosm macrocosm if we're a
whole the microcosm related to the
macrocosm of all created being
but that entirety of created being is
not you might say self-sufficient there
is a further end that it's ordered
ordained to or de not her in latin right
you know you could say oriented towards
as well then whatever is going to be
happiness for us is not going to be in
that macrocosm it's going to be what
lies beyond it and provides that with
its own meaning and significance and for
Thomas that's God right so he says again
the last end of the human being is not
the good of the universe which is not a
bad thing but God itself the third one
he actually asserts here and this is
again where controversies have arisen
among interpreters of Thomas that we are
in fact capable of this highest infinite
good which is God as an object cop Hoxie
says what objective that is that the
will can in fact desire God he says
created good is not less than that good
of which man is capable as of something
intrinsic and inherent to that to a
person but it is less than the
of which a person is capable so we have
natural desires for all sorts of goods
that exist created things but we also
have another desire that goes beyond
that entire spectrum or cosmos or
whatever you want to call it of created
goods and he says that you know it is
less than the good of which we are
capable as of as of an object and which
is infinite so again you know we do have
some sort of capacity however dim it may
be however unformed and you know in need
of Education it may be that directs us
towards something that surpasses any
order of created goods or even the
totality of created goods as a whole so
a lot going on here in this this section
and the ultimate conclusion of it is
where does human happiness lie it's
going to reside ultimately in God not in
any created good
you